me hi Eleanor Rock has been in Georgia
China and India she's visited more than
50 countries in the last four years to
capture images of female beauty
when I started this project I didn't
have this idea about a global project I
was just aiming for something of
curiosity for myself still doing it
required a leap of faith
no rope quit her job at a TV production
company in Bucharest
at first she lived off her savings then
she started financing her trips through
crowdfunding whether in Myanmar Germany
or Italy the streets and markets are her
workplace no rope approaches women and
photographs them then and there it's
very instinctual process it's a very
maybe some chemistry is going on maybe
some energies are going to be exchanged
between me and that person sometimes
it's just one look and I'm very drawn to
that person in Berlin the Romanian
photographer has been preparing for her
first major solo show she wants
everything to be perfect as these photos
have become part of her life you have to
dedicate yourself completely towards
something that you believe in and
sometimes it just works out sometimes it
doesn't but you have to try otherwise is
like all the women that they approached
many of them they said no I will not be
part of your project I'm afraid and I
didn't give up that's the key in
everything never give up never give up
recently norik also began to collect the
women's stories to ask them about the
challenges in their lives
this woman in Germany beat cancer twice
she fled with her daughters from
war-torn Syria and she works in one of
the most remote regions in the world
these women are all heroes they are
heroes of day-to-day life they are
usually not noticed they go unnoticed
unfortunately but they are heroes for
their families they are heroes for their
friends and I just celebrate them now
their stories and photos have been
published in a book called the Atlas of
beauty it's meant to send a message
everywhere in different forms of course
I think it doesn't have a definition I
think this is our problem as humans
because we try to put it in a box I
think we have to take it out of the box
and understand that beauty has so many
forms
[Music]
soon mihaela no rook will set off again
there are still many countries and more
forms of beauty to explore her project
is far from over
[Music]